what is going on there citizens of the rejection
we are going to watch she-hulk episode dose today
thank you for joining us john how's your day
going it's getting a lot better now good to hear
koi sun how is your day going very well you're
wearing the same shirt as last week yeah i know
that's how i do and koi knows how microphones work
sometimes that sounds like a pilot on an airplane
it's nice having koi back here with us since i'm
doing so many solo and quite you know you guys are
watching those koi's comic corners they're great
i also follow him on tick tock there's a lot of
stuff over there he's always asking me to plug
it and i'm like shut up i call them at midnight
yeah guys i'm gonna be wearing
the same green shirt and daredevil
for the next nine weeks i'm committed until our
marvel shirt comes in from shop zero edition.com
then i might change it up but this beanie
stink alrighty people listen up leave a like
smash that like button subscribe and click
that notification bell get notified when i
react when the next she-hulk is up okay that's
serious business here full-interaction watch
alongs recycled with the time code meaning
your own copy over at our patreon page for
super sexy rejects cover a bunch of
crap over there exclusively as well
and prepper team thank you guys for helping
set this down let's watch the marvel
sketches show a stunning scene from the
metropolitan courthouse super influencer
can you tell us about what you saw today
yeah yeah yeah so this chick pretty decent
like like a chick a she-hulk exactly
that's for somebody called she hulk which
can't possibly be what they're calling me
lady hole girl hulk she hold come
on just give them what they want
so dumb i can't even exist without being
a derivative of the hulk that's a pretty
dumb name too hmm neat little trick you pulled
there walters but don't you think it's a little
unsportsmanlike to suddenly debut superpowers
just to drum up publicity for yourself only you
would think that seriously how did you get these
powers i really don't feel like talking about it
nepotism you knew it jesus let's check over there
i'm gonna go talk to it it i relate to that guy
you could be an avenger do the avengers
offer health care maternity leave a pension
it's a big problem tony had jen can i talk to
you for a moment of course sir what is that
could you uh go back to jen jen this
is a serious conversation uh sure
all the booze in her system that's great we didn't
win the case oh yeah we did glk and had a declared
a mistrial because you as your uh like she-hulk
that is not what i call it how is it her fault
what was i supposed to do like let them get
hit in the face with a desk and then they
have blunt force trauma and they're all bleeding
out all over the courtroom floor no i'm sorry oh
i'm sorry two boss no jen i'm sorry i have to
let you go what jeez wait wait you're firing me
oh my god a logo hey
oh i hope that keeps up that motif we're not
prepared to offer you the position at this time
sorry it's a no we just can't take the
risk of a sideshow that was clever at the
background getting the lesser and lesser seeming
offices so so smart montage good observations
film comic book reference jen what are you doing
eye on the prize come on seriously said iron man
3's is that what it said no what fire it again
captain america's ass that's her phone background
some of this production design reminds me
the matrix because everything's just so great
there is no spoon jennifer walters you don't
have to worry about getting fired i already told
everyone so it won't be awkward oh no hi
everybody hi jen you're gonna fire him
chad chad ted so to bring it up i said don't bring
it up it's okay dad i yes got fired but it's fine
big news so i got uh promoted to manager
over at the best buy manager all right chad
enjoyed and promoted employed
and promoted that hawkeye guy
what happens to those arrows of his i mean does
he go around and collect them when he's done
jenny nobody calls me that i'm just gonna put this
out there melanie is a stylist you know she could
help you let's get this hair more like she-hulks
oh hazardous believe those things lying around
you know like i thought i could keep this
at bay for i don't know how long eternity
well but it's just like i hate we're
loving thunder the thing that you were
dreading happened but look you're still
standing and now you get to keep moving on
me too he's a nice guy mobile on
the tv because the show's like that
easter egg ally mcbeals canon now i'd
like to offer you a job ah is this a joke
don't ever joke it's no easy feat against
glk h so i would like you to come work for us
you got me fired now you want to hire me to be
head of a new division yes take some time i accept
i will only do it if i can hire my own paralegal
non-negotiable i truly do not
care who your paralegal is yes
that's a building established
tall structurally sound corporate
we just started a super human law division and i
want you well the she-hulk to be the face of it oh
uh that means i'll expect you to be at work and
in court as the she-hulk not as a normal person
right now poor choice of words
can i change this way please
we are the first top-tier law firm to launch
an entire division dedicated to superhuman law
god is this why they hired me okay this
sucks i am totally qualified but now everyone
around here comics these dodos never had to
deal with this on their first day at work
but i'm curious what do you think about it i'm
uh agnostic interesting unprecedented for sure
spend the rest of the year worrying
about what i just said no it's good
look at everything it's getting us big-ass
windows yes a fully stocked mini fridge and a desk
i mean this is normal but this this is very fancy
bit she's great hey i love her hi there i'm pug
i'm also in the superhuman law division oh i'm i'm
jennifer walters i made you guys a welcome basket
oh that kind of looks so familiar it's adrian
chase romero it's andrew's history i didn't
realize it's not my second viewing
snacks and a map to the best bathroom
thank you the live deliveries of this show are
very good and then um tell bob thompson that he's
going to minneapolis because he hates the cold i
mean just tell him that mr holloway i'm so i can't
wait to take on whatever case you want to assign
yourself first case is the parole of emil blonsky
get right to it oh also known as abomination
mr blonsky has been serving his sentence
in an ultra high security prison i am very
familiar with mr blonsky sir i'm sorry but
i can't represent him this man tried to kill
my cousin bruce yeah that's quite all right
welcome
kind of neat how our clothes don't really
rip do not step past the yellow line
do not touch the glass separating you and the
prisoner abomination although we have taken
every precaution we cannot guarantee your
safety do you accept these conditions yes
sign here we haven't seen him mia blonsky in so
long so long it's hitting me right now because
we saw him as abomination in chongqi but we
haven't seen him yeah since 08. jennifer what was
first off namaste i was expecting abomination
right you won't be seeing much of him about
honestly i've completely transformed myself
physically obviously but also spiritually
i'm simply a male now russian born british
raised royal marines commando on loan to the
u.s government okay with seven soul mates that
i met through the prison pen pound program that
i want to start a new life with nice let's
talk about the elephant in the room shall we
your cousin the hulk
you know i tried to kill him you know so let's get
that out of the way it wasn't personal or anything
so i was under direct orders from your government
but then you went on a destructive rampage in
harlem that wasn't sanctioned by the government
yeah because they pumped me full of that super
soldier serum the serum the government gave you
caused your subsequent actions oh i thought i was
gonna be you know captain bloody america something
you know and now that very threat your cousin is
held up as some kind of hero and i'm locked up
in here i like this screen yeah thunderbolt setup
right here the parole board's gonna need to know
that you feel remorse for your actions to even
consider release absolutely i do see and i have
here uh various haikus that i've written oh boy
tons of remorse the sorrow oh you don't have
you'd like to experience them that's okay
if i were your attorney i would advise you
to speak truthfully from the heart instead
of trying to gauge what you think they might
want to hear that's all from my heart jen look
i just want to move on with my life
live in peace on a large piece of
property purchased for me by my seven
soul mates right think you can help
yeah i'll think about it thunderbolts
hey jen what's up bruce hey
um listen i got a new job hey
congratulations that's fantastic yeah but but
part of the deal is i have to take on emil blonsky
as a client and and i i couldn't do that without
talking to you first okay i mean it doesn't seem
like you hold a grudge at least you've never
talked about that before and and you're always
saying that you know everybody deserves a second
chance and and i'm not falling for an act here
he was so compelling and and maybe i want
to believe that he's reformed you know isn't
but rehabilitation of that matters
i think you're calling me to tell me you're taking
the job i'm calling you to tell you i'm taking
the job yes that's great jen you should actually
blonsky wrote me a really nice letter a while back
and a really heartfelt haiku and that fight was so
many years ago i'm a completely different person
they just acknowledged oh fourth
wall break well used i'm a completely
different one literally i end up naming you anyway
don't even no i love that that's
got a nice ring to it she-hulk
attorney at law yeah that's the title dips
this show you coming to l.a anytime soon yeah
probably not for a minute i got some
things i got to take care of oh my goodness
always on planes i've already got a winning
strategy and it is a hundred percent in the
bag glad to hear it uh you might want to take a
look at the news right yes just the general news
so far there have been no statements made by
emil blonsky's attorney after shocking footage
what appears to be an underground fight club
after having somehow oh [__] yeah that sucks
oh what oh damn oh such a good cliffhanger they're
so good oh we better get a mid credits with the
haiku that was such a good cliffhanger this show's
very good it is very good it's my assessment yeah
i think they uh i think they eliminated um by a
little bit a second episode i i liked it more than
the first one for sure there's a lot more i think
they just needed to establish the world quickly
in the first one an hour in yeah it's really
well done first one was kind of like a prologue
to get hurt into the world this is like the real
first episode yeah exactly this is what the show
will be like from now on this this is different
than the yeah just the first opening and then and
there was a shield logo on that one yeah like some
of them are the same but others are being updated
there's like a little hulk movie in here oh
side hulk story or is it just a big setup
you wonder if they're just like yeah they're
setting something up is it just every episode
bruce is gonna be somewhere else random
or is this yeah spin-off territory i
think that's all the roughly we might get
i don't know 4k is this thing nobody does
but you still need it dude i don't know
what i'm doing down here i'm tired i've
turned to the left i'm turning it right look 10
o'clock i don't know drop it down rub it down
do not touch these wires again no i could have
done that there you go watch out for the lamb
i'm glad you're staying hydrated dad but this
seems a little excessive oh yeah do that yep okay
i like this show i do too all right koi
has a heart out in the next nine minutes
no no this is how it rolls when koi is here i'm
the problem you always yeah white man always hope
hiring people for the wrong reasons right this
was strategically planned for this year yep
greg commentary jesus guys wait you should
go first oh no i went first last time drums
go first you should go first uh yeah no
no no i really really enjoyed this toy
what did you think sure this
is how i lose the reject nation
pitting us against each other is how
i believe yeah pick your favorite one
he tried to do it with eric voss and it didn't
take so now he's trying to do it with john yeah
like i like i mean i have too much fun sometimes
johnny okay state your opinion for the jury
defend why you legitimately like this show
uh no no yeah yeah i agree i liked that this
built well upon the first one that it really does
establish i mean you know i'm sure they'll throw
us curveballs and surprises but it feels like
now we have the tone of the show complete and
i really liked uh what they're sort of getting at
with um both just showing the struggles that she
faces and i'm sure a lot of women face you know as
they build a career and as you you know you it's
hard to do the right thing sometimes and sometimes
you're not rewarded for doing so and then how
they relate that over to emil blonsky and his
situation and i don't know what this whole prison
break thing is going to result in i want to still
believe that he ultimately will be a sympathetic
character but i really like that they had that
thing to connect over of like hey i was just
put in this position of you know i thought i was
doing the right thing i thought i was the good guy
and here i come to find that i've been manipulated
and turned into you know this this force and so
like i was like oh cool like that's a kind of
universal and a mutual uh identification moment
that i thought was really nice and uh and spoke to
and also getting hired off of her looks well yeah
there's yeah that too it's like it's not about
what you know or your expertise it's about you
know yeah the the appearance and it's about us you
know i'm sure you know having you know we're the
first ones to open up this progressive new office
and we want you to be our poster child like yeah
there's a lot of that sort of corporaty uh you
know false uh uh posturing and virtue signaling
sort of uh nuance going on there and things
like that but i'm curious too to see how uh her
relation i feel like that's gonna be a interesting
sometimes harsh sometimes fun relationship between
her and her boss but the show did establish
that she was gonna win before that whole fiasco
happened yeah that's just so she actually is
skilled like it's not solely just because of
her appearance yeah yeah but that she was gonna
actually win it itself yeah all right coy go
i love that this felt like a goddamn comic book
not only did it have that like single frame that
felt like you turned the page and there's like the
thing you experienced from chung chi which is very
comically like the the use of the interwoven world
in the mcu has always been very well handled but
now in phase four i feel like we've got multiple
timelines that are happening simultaneously like
with the end of hawkeye where we had you know the
spider-man moment i love that this is feeling like
a world it's feeling fleshed out so we get shields
journey carrying forward we get that tie into
where it lies in time loud chung chi but we also
get a launching point for hulk so this this really
feels like when you're reading marvel comics it
all feels like a big tapestry i really love the
character growth i agree with greg that the first
episode and it's actually funny the things that i
forgave about the first episode i i had those
three things that were qualms still loved the
episode but i do feel like that was worth it to
hurry to this episode too i love that this is
nine episodes because now we have eight episodes
of this because episode one just kind of got us
there like it was like hey love their chemistry
love this relationship you're gonna love shield
we're gonna let all this fly by i would have
loved if the pilot was like 45 minutes even
10 more minutes of just like her struggling her
succeeding a little bit more of of those things
we talked about but then it's worth all of that
for eight episodes of this attorney show like i'm
genuinely so excited for where this goes and i've
loved most of the marvel tv shows but this one
feels like the most like a show like
i i feel like i'm watching a 90s show
that happens to be a character i love i this feels
like when i would watch stuff with my family and
be like and next week i'll come back but it's not
something i love so it's combining my two great
loves like watching stuff that i enjoy with my
family and comic books that's actually part of its
strength uh weirdly enough because a lot of times
with these big shows there the pitch is always we
made like a six-hour movie yeah and then sometimes
it feels like it's kind of caught now in between
being a show and being a movie so that at times
you're like i wish it was kind of longer now or
maybe this didn't need to be as long so actually
embracing the fact that it's a tv show i think the
boys does that well and this is just gonna say
boys they took that eric cripp keynote of maybe
instead of writing your six hour movie you should
write six great episodes of tv yeah and i think
that's what they've done here is because this is
this is really strong i i like that they give like
the thing that we were talking about the first
episode of not really having much of a struggle
that's going to be more of an internal struggle
that's carried over here and 10 times more you
know her getting fired because it's like the
last episode ended on look again not another
struggle super villain shows up whoops the super
villain's ass not a problem yeah and then it picks
up right here and it's like oh that's actually
a major problem for her of everything that just
occurred and you know feeling objectified too
off of it and yeah i like the commentary on be
like see to me that is a little bit more of just
that i know this is already i'm not going to spend
forever talking about that camp is going to have
a [__] issue with it because it's like yeah the
writing of episode one with some of that felt
like this could have been more fleshed out and
more nuanced and and instead of just feeling
like okay you're just kind of talking to me
and here they're carrying over that commentary
in the work field in the you know pr field in
the image field they're carrying over that type
of commentary but in a way that i actually feel
is imbued within the world and makes a lot of
sense and doesn't feel like i'm being talked to
and so i really liked it that's kind of a little
bit again if they had that like ten more texts
yeah that first episode then i would have had i
wouldn't have had kind of that criticism towards
some of that dialogue but here i think that it's
actually done really well i don't feel pandered
yeah i know there's gonna be a lot of people who
automatically already gonna feel like oh my god
but leave don't don't be here um because this
this right here i'm like no that's the right
touch because it also has this really sweet tone
to it like i really enjoy the tone a lot i i'm not
familiar with ally mcbeal like i it was a show
that existed and i saw commercials for all the
time when i was a kid but i didn't actually
watch the show i know you saw the practice
because you had someone who worked
on it his dad was dead i had a guy
and sliders have you heard of sliders
the movie about people in portals
it's a series it was a series of jerry o'connell
yeah oh no way that's awesome i love jerry
o'connell and other things he worked on the
thing back in the day that's awesome he was
a trainee yeah that's crazy didn't know any of
that learned something about james dot com john
of the humphreys
and one thing i'll say is to add to the actual
conversation my dad's rad uh but but yeah uh
one thing is uh with the pacing and the nuances
and things like that often times during these
scenes whenever i have a a like a notice moment
it's always like i could tell that scene went on
longer and they trimmed it down so i feel like
it's all there but one thing that this episode
made me realize that's been great about phase four
i think in particular is you look at like shangchi
you look at miss marvel you look at this they're
really great at doing best friends and family
environment and just like plopping you in like
some of those family scenes i wish did have more
time again just breathe because they do become
just like here's your large character note however
cliche yeah and so like during that scene with
the dad i was like okay i get somebody probably
was like we need to speed this up but i wish
they could really have a bonding chat back and
forth but even despite that i thought the actors
at least and just the kind of environment they
drew for those was really nice and touching and
i hope for the i hope they could get to that miss
marvel level like oh we're really spending some
time with them and that phone call with bruce
is so good yeah that was such a great use of both
those characters and then the reveal was excellent
i think the way again i'm i'm bringing them
up because of the two most recent shows or
no no let me do it again i'm bringing them
because of the two most recent women what gets
more engaged the two most recent it yeah things
things the two most recent things to be here
no but imam valani and tatiana maslany they
there's there's that kind of quality okay i need
i need to make sure i say this properly um okay
paul rudd as ant-man i'm like i see paul rudd
still you know what i mean yeah um there's certain
characters with some of these roles that i'm like
wow they are just this person like they are that
character they are this person and i feel like
both the man vulani and tatiana maslany they just
are them sarah and the casting team behind
this they've found these characters they're
brilliant performers like they're so they're so
nuanced without relying on like being nuanced
i am the actor because they keep so much life and
real relatable personality and they just sound so
[__] natural when they're talking and so i
love i i absolutely love her performance like
i'm just watching her at all like dad she's
so good and she makes up for a lot of when
the because again the same i feel like whatever
thing i said about cgi in the first episode is
going to be applied here sometimes it's going to
look good so i'm just going to look a little off
whatever but it's not as distracting to me because
i'm so um i'm i'm enjoying the show so much that i
was like whatever it's the game yeah i'm going
to own i i didn't watch uh orange is the new
black uh is that that's her show right the uh
titanic lonnie she had a show where she played
multiple character shows she had a show where
she played a lot of different characters and
i didn't watch it but i did see her in stronger
and she's incredible and stronger but it's a very
very dramatic performance so i didn't have a lot
of exposure to her in a comedic role and i know
jennifer walters from the comic book being one of
the first characters to break the fourth wall in
a major comic book she is she's she is nailing
it yeah and i didn't know i had i didn't have
enough exposure to her other work that i just
like knew hey i know she's a very strong actress
i've supported her as she'll from the beginning
because of stronger but now seeing her comedy in
this i want to watch the thing she's known for
like i'm i'm now a fan of her to be like i want
to go retroactively discover the glory that is
her work yeah she's freaking brilliant so good
experience the mausoleums yeah and like i'm
appreciating i appreciate the way they are
building out this world because it's done it does
feel like a comic book show and it's done in this
really i don't i can't quite find the i feel like
everyone's already said it in this discussion
i'm so happy this is really snappy it's snappy
it's enjoyable and i found myself wanting more
like when it was done not not in a bad way like
when it ended i was like i wasn't expecting it
to end nor did it end abruptly it ended in a way
i'm like no i wanna i wanna keep watching that was
really enjoyable when a show does a good three-act
structure that you're like i didn't even notice
that it was almost over because i'm actually in oh
no cliffhanger like yeah and instead of trying to
do this six hour and a six to nine hour movie
thing they're allowing for a specific journey
per episode you know like where she had to come
to with a place of acceptance in the first episode
and then here you know having to deal with
these things and then confront bruce about
having to deal with the decision and then also
now that she's out in the public there's like
little journeys little arcs in between each one
there's lessons to be learned in each episode
and so i think that is a big strength already
demonstrated in these last two episodes
and uh i i really like um i like the whole thing
with the lawyer division i'm sure that's that's
a comic thing right now let's see what happens
is she's representing superheroes and i could
see that you know folding in uh you know obviously
daredevil but also even things like jessica jones
as a private eye that's a superhero that could
even lead the awesome and like the heroes for
hire uh this episode was called attorney for
hire even talk about that i can see luke cage
there was this quote going around on twitter
about this either director or writer talking
about how they would take these characters
who uh were often really serious in these
films and they get a chance of playing the
tone of she-hulk and of course that led
to a lot of like comedy what what they're
terrible hilarious uh so that's what it is
so to see what to get a flavor of that
with emil i was listening to his monologue
and i'm like no he's getting some of
that humor in there it's not too much
they haven't joked him up to the point where
i'm like now i'm laughing at emil blonsky and
this the speech he was making i was like you know
what you're making a really good point actually
you were the hero they hired that movie but he's
a hero in the show um potentially yeah yeah hulk
exactly yeah because because emil blonsky in that
movie they were like we're the one we need you
to hire we're gonna inject you and fill you up
drug yourself in that movie performance is all
like eyebrow mustache twirling and here he is a
hero yeah so i think that they did uh i want to
make sure that sometimes you're talking about emil
and hulk or are you talking about both i'm talking
about emil in hulk in hulk yeah i'm saying in the
film this is the show in the film swirling his
mustache swirling villain in the sh in the movie
in the movie but he was he's making a point though
that is true was that they hired him thinking he'd
be the hero who could take down the hulk which is
the beauty of nuanced characters yes like kingpin
and daredevil like this is that i think they
they wrote that in so well because to put that in
the context of his perspective and to watch how
he's changed and you give him actual personality
that's freaking tim roth he's an amazing actress
a great actor during that scene i was sitting
there thinking oh man he must actually be having
like a a good enriching time performing right
especially with those recent quotes from like
mickey rourke about like you know about his
time working with marvel and like ah you know
they're not willing to go in and give us some
character to actually work with i was like it
seems like they have learned to really do
that with their especially veteran actors
and and their new talent too yeah it gets
something more fun and interesting to do
instead of just like you i won't i want more
yeah like this give us give us the haiku
i hope that's like a publicity thing i
hope you like get it out there in the world
so yeah i thought that was that's an
it's a very fascinating chapter to
explore now it makes sense why wong
would be getting into trouble yeah
a lawyer too because oh these shang chi things
are going to have repercussions and i really think
it's setting up thunderbolts that whole speech
felt like oh we're the good guys oh my seventh
come on it's right there i mean they've already
established that thunderbolts are coming
right it's just like i just didn't think it would
be like in his first minute of screen time yeah i
think they'd be like and this is the thunderbolt
setup and i was like that is so yeah i'm enjoying
it a lot and i think that the show is doing a
really it's a really fun time it's it's genuine
it's like genuine sincere fun with a lot of heart
and in a way that also keeps them mcu growing yeah
man i think that's the thing that a lot of the
times that we're we're sort of wanting is like you
know i do want some of that mcu world building as
well and it's but it's not like solely dependent
on that yeah and yet you're also getting that
you're getting to have your cake it doesn't feel
shameless it doesn't feel like it's like oh you
use this character you notice that you're nerds
like it feels like it's a useful tool it's the
appropriate environment to do a lot of this and
that's why i think the cameos in this and i though
some of the comments in that koi's comment corner
watch it uh about cameos in the show i think
you're gonna feel good because they've already
done it so well i think this is the only way
to have some c and d list characters that
like i'd love to see incorporated give me stilt
man i don't want to see stiltman anywhere else
but like this would be a great way to
do a lot of those characters in tone
scar is coming scar so he like beat the person
with the ship yeah that that's weird to me i
don't know who was flying that ship he's gone
now he's just like annihilated out of space
maybe they came to a peaceful agreement or
maybe there was no one in that ship and it was
automatically autopiloted yeah they opened there's
jessica bloom as a hologram being like my champion
you're under contract all right guys well
um hey before we go thanks for the patreon
adelia chamberlain you are more than a she-hulk
yo you're a greg hulk oh that's what i call you
right so adelia um you might know of her
koi oh um she helps run uh let's get ready
to what's it called yeah good she also got
my discord she's a she's a swedish oh so you
do know adelia she's awesome yeah she's the
best she's a sweetheart she actually like i
don't know how to use a discord and she's
been very patient with my being very dumb
yeah she's she is a big heart and soul of our
patron she's been with us forever had some very
long conversations with her only met her in person
that one time at this moment it was good chilling
with you though yeah so i i think what i've
learned today ideally is koi knows who you are
i appreciate you i thank you for your patience
i think you're very very kind and welcoming to
people in the movie world and that is not always
the case and i think you're a great bridge between
us folk that are having to deal with not
great people and the good like everyone
you've connected me to has been rad you're
a great gateway to the people we might
not meet otherwise and we appreciate you
i like how you counted the things you were listing
i like to make sure that people won your kind
all right adelia all right see you guys thank you
for being here bye bye i like lists i'm a virgo